donner la parole aux présidents
christian cambon pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
le président tout d'abord le groupe des
républicains auxquels je j'appartiens
s'associer à l'hommage que vous avez
rendu à notre regretté collègue léonard
qui appartient notre région ile de
france
monsieur le premier ministre
mahler et honte aux oppresseurs du
peuple malien voilà bien ce que l'on
entend maintenant régulièrement dans les
manifestations
hostiles à la france au mali alors que
nous sommes nous y sommes présents
depuis plus de huit ans que 58 de nos
soldats y ont laissé la vie et que des
centaines de blessés garderont une
marque pour leur vie entière
dans cette fuite en avant l' la junte
malienne a manifestement décidé de faire
porter à la france le bouc émissaire de
lui faire jouer le rôle de bouc
émissaire de toutes ses propres
difficultés
la liste des humiliations que le mali
nous fait connaître actuellement nous
fait subir est assez longue pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de véritable réponse de la
part de notre gouvernement
nos accords militaires ont été dénoncés
ils nous liait depuis des années
le ciel malien utile l'espace aérien du
mali nous est interdit sur une très
grande partie à la demande de des
milices wagner ces mêmes milices wagner
ses véritables soudards des temps
modernes s'installe définitivement dans
cette perspective pour eux nous en
chasser est prélevée sur ce malheureux
pays un tribut sur les ressources et les
moyens financiers dont malheureusement
le mal dit n'avait guère besoin
dernièrement date le danemark qui avait
contribué qui avait manifesté sa volonté
de contribuer à l'effort que nous
portons attaque où il a été éconduit et
a dû rentrer chez lui enfin humiliation
suprême
notre ambassadeur a été rappelé dans un
délai de 72 heures ce qui donne plutôt
l'impression d'une expulsion et ce qui
est une véritable humiliation pour nous
alors face à ces provocations qui sont
des provocations délibérées la france ne
peut pas restée impuissante faute de
d'en subir les conséquences à la fois
pour sa crédibilité en afrique mais
aussi en europe
viendra le temps de faire le bilan des
échecs des erreurs de tout ce qui a pu
être mal fait dans cette dans cette
affaire ma question aujourd'hui elle est
très simple qu'est ce que vous comptez
faire que ce que vous comptez faire
décidez vous de rester au mali contre la
volonté de ses dirigeants et au risque
de pénaliser nos soldats et de risquer
leur vie est-ce que vous souhaitez que
l'on s'installe au burkina faso qui sort
d'un coup d'état très affaibli est ce qu
il convient d'aller au niger mais le
niger
mais le niger nous demande de ne pas
accueillir takouba ou bien est
faudra-t-il aller au tchad qui est
distant de 2600 km c'est la véritable
problème alors monsieur le premier
ministre dit au sénat ce qu'il convient
car fait le par respect pour le
sacrifice qui a été consenti à nos
concitoyens et pour les 53 les 58 morts
que nous avons perdu
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs sénateurs monsieur le
président quand bon
je reprends don de la parole après avoir
répondu au président qu'à nerfs vous
avez parlé d' humiliation il ya
incontestablement une très grave crise
politique avec le mali et c'est
précisément et que vouliez-vous qu'elle
fit d'autres parce que la france a très
fermement par la seule d'ailleurs mais
la france dont je réponds devant vous de
l'action a très fermement condamné tout
ce que vous avez précisément décrits et
qui est à la seule
imputation de la junte militaire
malienne qu'effectivement ce régime a
décidé entre autres de renvoyer notre
ambassadeur je rappelle encore ici que
le représentant la cedeao a également
été renvoyé que le danemark a fait
l'objet des décisions que vous avez
monsieur le président rappelait mais
permettez-moi de le dire c'est pas une
humiliation que voulez vous confie qu'on
approuve le fait que le régime mal hier
renvoie notre ambassadeur montre la
fermeté dont nous avons fait preuve dans
la condamnation de ce qui s'y passe et
nous avons parfaitement bien fait
monsieur le président alors certes c'est
un élément nouveau c'est un élément
nouveau dans la stratégie globale
de notre présence dans cette région du
mois nous devrons faire évoluer notre
dispositif opérationnel pour lutter
contre théorise sujet n'est pas le mali
faisait parler du niger d'autres états
contre le terrorisme dans cette zone
ainsi que je l'indiquais tout à l'heure
et j'insiste auprès du sénat c'est pas
simplement un problème franco malien
cinquième du mali d'un lutte contre
terrorisme international l'europe est au
rendez vous je vous rappelle que les
ministres se sont réunis le 24 janvier
et qu' ils vont prendre ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères de
l'union européenne des sanctions contre
cet état que la cedeao vous savait
parfaitement tout ça monsieur peur s'est
réuni et que nous continuerons à
travailler dans ce cadre multilatéral à
la fois à la réaction et à l'évolution
de notre dispositif le parlement
monsieur le président je reviens vers le
président kader le parlement évidemment
mérite d'être parfaitement informée de
cette situation et donc je le dis il y
aura il y aura le travaux des
commissions dont la vôtre et oui le
gouvernement organisera un débat sur la
base de l'article 50-1 de la
constitution sur ce sujet extrêmement
important